- welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is
Michael Ellis and today we will be
talking about how to enhance your G
suite efficiency with Chrome you can ask
questions anytime on the platform we
have Googlers on standby to answer them
let's get started
first I want to talk a little bit about
the evolution of enterprise and where
end-user computing has come to today
today's movement we call the cloud mover
but it actually starts way back when
when we were originally talking
mainframes in the 1990 came more
powerful with the rise of the PC
movement so everyone started to get
computers on their desks which were more
powerful than the traditional mainframe
workstations they were working with this
also brought the rise of software so
end-users began to install software
package software directly on their
workstations this also led to an
increase in the need for software from a
security standpoint so this now required
the likes of things like antivirus and
firewalls to be installed directly on
these workstations and then starting in
2000 with the rise of the internet
movement we saw more and more computing
power being brought to the cloud and was
really the beginning of the cloud
movement as we transition through the
2000s and users became more and more
mobile so this meant that users now had
more power that they had access from
from their actual phones versus what
they were traditionally using on their
desktops this is also the rise of the
social movement right so end-users
expected to become more collaborative
they expected inherently that as I start
to use tools to work with my colleagues
that would be able to just inherently
collaborate without the need to install
desktop software continuing through the
2000s we actually saw a greater rise in
applications right and this is where we
started to see people start to bring
tablets to the enterprise expecting that
they would constantly have access and
access to the content that they need
with this tremendous a wealth of power
of computing in the backend and now here
we are today in the cloud movement and
the interesting part is is that we
haven't really seen a transition from
the PC computing age right we're still
seeing a lot of people - playing
workstation
with operating systems on top of those
platforms they have to continue to
install security software so as we've
seen a transition of data to the cloud
and computing to the cloud
we actually haven't fundamentally
changed how we have end-users access
that compute resource but think about
what you're already doing with your G
suite investment you're already adopting
the cloud to give yourself a competitive
advantage a great set is 70% of
forward-thinking companies on forbes
cloud 100 lists are active G suite
customers many of you are on this
webcast today think about some of the
values that are striving for today for
your end users there's inherent
intelligence inside of these
applications where they're using Gmail
with suggested replies or you're using
our brand new hangouts chat product you
have access to a wealth of artificial
intelligence built directly in to these
applications without requiring that your
users are installing software directly
on the workstations there was a natural
culture of collaboration that comes with
G suite right the users are naturally
looking to share content with each other
and they're expecting that those
connections will just happen inherently
on top of the platform they're not
thinking about the devices that they're
using they're just looking at being able
to reach out to their colleagues to get
answers connected knowledge is I want to
be able to search for the content no
matter where I am when I want access to
that and Google Drive is really driven a
large innovation there right where you
have the ability to access this content
in your mobile device or on your desktop
and again bringing the capabilities of
artificial intelligence to do things
like suggest documents for you to work
on the first time that you access your
drive and then simple and secure
manageability as you know the entire
control panel for G suite is managed
directly within the Google cloud and
this allows you to kind of not have to
be concerned about security capabilities
its inherent to the platform we allow
you to have level of controls from
sharing everything publicly that you
want your users to be able to share all
the way to very find two data controls
to allow you to ensure that your users
are not sharing data outside the bounds
of your organization so you're already
getting a lot of the advantages of cloud
by already being on G suite but again
traditionally we're seeing a lot of
customers are continuing to leverage
existing workstations and we think
there's an opportunity for us to
innovate with our customers to drive
new types of business advantages and we
truly believe that the cloud is the spot
where we're gonna help you be able to
innovate from a security perspective
we're finding more and more
organizations are absolutely adopting
more and more applications inside the
cloud whether it's things like GCE and
leveraging collaboration capabilities to
ERP capabilities to things like
Salesforce from a CRM perspective all
the way to popular HR providers we're
seeing more and more organizations adopt
these platforms to become a cloud first
organization to take advantage of the
security innovations in the cloud to put
their most sensitive data like CRM and
HR data into these secure cloud-based
tools what we're finding is because of
this access to cloud-based applications
users are expecting more and more that
they want to be able to access these
applications and use their capabilities
no matter where they are so what that
means is they want to be able to whether
I'm sitting on a Windows desktop or I'm
actively using my iPhone or I'm sitting
currently on an Android tablet I want to
have the same capabilities of being
highly mobile and what we've
traditionally seen as many of these
endpoints aren't necessarily catered to
that experience but we're finding more
and more applications or allowing users
to bring these capabilities no matter
which device they want to use and
unfortunately the number of security
taxes on the rise and they're becoming
absolutely more and more advanced we're
seeing a great rise and things like
phishing attacks and targeted phishing
attacks called spear phishing we're also
seeing a rise of malware I just saw a
recent article that was discussing the
rise of ransomware and a recent
municipality where they actually had to
send their employees home so already
hackers know that there is a target by
leveraging the existing endpoints out
there they know that there's a vector to
get into organizations and they're
leveraging that to then springboard into
other applications that may be in the
cloud so we think this is a really great
opportunity to actually address that
endpoint security strategy but what we
have found legacy endpoints are really
not built to support security and
certainly have not transitioned well
into the the modern computing age right
you think about your your your phone
when you're using application when's the
last time you thought about things like
a firewall on your phone or you've
thought about the capabilities of you
know
antivirus updates we traditionally on
next-generation computing platforms
don't really think about that stuff but
we're very used to from an end-user
computing perspective putting an
endpoint out there and having to think
about this entire strategy every single
time and as organizations are making the
transition to Windows 10 we have to
consider this all over again right so
whether it's partnering with a virus
vendor worrying about software updates
that we have to deal with sometimes very
last-minute as next generation attacks
come out patching that operating system
the transition to Windows 7 to Windows
10 is a very very large transition for
customers that a lot of them are taking
their time with upgrading Hardware right
getting a new piece of hardware means
you have to create new images and then
how do you backup this data that is not
currently being based within the cloud
you have to figure out these strategies
and even things like encryption as well
and we think this is the opportunity to
take a look at what we offer with Chrome
OS and the capabilities we offer to our
enterprise customers and let's think
about it
organizations are driven to say I want
these two strategies to be combined
right I want my organization to be more
collaborative to absolutely embrace next
generation security using the
capabilities of the cloud but I don't
want to be concerned about endpoint
security I I am not in the business of
needing to lock down my workstations
so organizations are coming to Google
and saying there must be a strategy
around this around giving our users
next-generation and points that they
absolutely can fall in love with and be
able to leverage those to securely
access tools whether they're on G suite
or other cloud-based applications out
there and that's exactly where Chrome
Enterprise comes into the picture
customers often ask us what is the
difference between chrome enterprise and
Chrome OS and Chrome Enterprise is the
offering that we have for both
management and support of Chrome OS
devices so the Chrome OS devices that
you can use as an enterprise are the
same ones that you could purchase from
your existing hardware vendors or go out
to your favorite electronics or and
purchase those and by applying the
Chrome Enterprise license you now have
the capabilities to fully control and
manage that cloud-based endpoint and
pass down security policies and access
aesthetic applications that you want to
dictate to your user and we've done many
advancements specifically in the
enterprise for our
customers to make sure they're getting
the capabilities that they need out of
the platform we've increased the amount
of productivity apps that are currently
available on the platform traditionally
it just was web-based applications and
chrome applications we've now extended
that ecosystem to the Android Play Store
as well giving us full capabilities to
now install applications directly on
these endpoints and then also offer
updated applications as they come to the
Play Store built-in security protections
directly in which we'll talk a little
bit of later on but something unique to
this platform versus what you may see
some from the competitors or some of the
other offerings out there is that we
directly update the operating systems
right from Google so that means whether
you're working with Dell HP Lenovo
whoever your favorite vendor is you can
continue to leverage those endpoints
that your users absolutely fall in love
with but you're actually getting direct
oh s updates from Google so that that
means you don't have to worry about
those vendors having to certify a patch
before it's released to your endpoints
and this is more and more important as
we're seeing more and more kind of zero
day attacks being offered out there the
great part is is it is tightly
integrated to your existing G suite
console optionally tightly integrated
which we'll talk about a little later on
what this means is you can actually
manage your entire fleet of devices so
we're talking hundreds if not tens of
thousands of devices directly manage
from your G suite console
although requires is the purchase of a
Chrome Enterprise license and then you
then have the capabilities of managing
all the policies directly on that device
and automatic updates come with support
directly from Google as well so that
means if you ever run into an issue
whether it's a hardware issue or a
software issue and you need to reach out
to Google for support on these you get
direct 24/7 365 support from Google
cloud support team to guide you through
any issues that you're having and we
think by combining these two platforms
together that you'll get truly
next-generation security capabilities
piece of lime LT lite our multi-layer
security means that you have the
capabilities to no matter what whether
it's a piece of hardware or piece of
software be able to make sure that the
policies are truly locking down the
device and making sure that you don't
have to be concerned about oh I have to
update the antivirus oh I have to update
the
firewall on top of this hassle free
management built in management directly
from Google's cloud for this platform
that means that from a management
perspective you're going to the same
console that you're using today and
you're getting more value from the
existing management platform that you're
using used to with less cost and we'll
talk about that a little later on from
an ROI perspective and a consistent
experience no matter the type of device
you're using whether it's a Chrome OS
Chromebook or you're using a Chrome box
the same exact experience for your end
users no matter where they sit and which
types of devices they're currently using
so let's talk a little bit about the
protections that come inherent to the
platform you get automatic security
updates directly from Google that means
when that next generation of
vulnerability comes out you'll come
directly to Google support for
assistance and those updates will come
directly from the Google cloud deliver
directly down to your endpoints things
that you're possibly used to from the
from the Chrome browser capabilities but
the ability to actually isolate
individual processes this is a lot of
what you see on a lot of modern modern
mobile platforms as well so this is
essentially processes cannot read data
from each other that allows them to run
isolated so if there was ever a
vulnerability in a single application it
wouldn't bleed over to the rest of the
operating system or to other
applications currently running on that
device and then other browser technology
that you're possibly used to things like
Safe Browsing so leveraging Google's
cloud to see if there's any nefarious
websites that your users are going to
and preventing them from directly
accessing them on those devices and then
I also secure app access right so making
sure the applications that your users
are accessing are delivered from a web
store from the Play Store so they've
gone through security audits before
they're actually delivered users cannot
siloed executables onto these devices to
be able to get around security controls
that you put on them in a reduced TCO
right we're really driving down the
price of these devices right finding a
spot where we think that enterprises
were will to use these at scale at a
price point that's not like many of the
other platforms that they're used to low
end user support costs right because
these devices are very easy to write
very shareable we think it's a great
opportunity to also lower the support
cost think of the time that goes into
you know OS management re having to
reimage a device right this is time that
costs you from a support perspective
when we think by leveraging this
platform you have these capabilities
built directly in and a future-proof
solution so as we continue to make
innovations on Chrome OS as we continue
to add new capabilities like that Google
assistant that these will be available
to you as a customer and you'll be able
to leverage these at your discretion
leveraging the control panel so that
means that it doesn't require that you
have to go out there buy a new device
that supports that new operating system
you're getting direct support from
Google for these devices for years to
come in a lot of the controls and
permissions that you're used to today
would also carry over to the Chrome OS
devices right so you can really have
great filter of policy and controls that
you're putting on these users so this
can be every restriction from disabling
users from going into an incognito mode
to actually controlling USB port access
right and these are as simple as
checkboxes directly in the control panel
leveraging a lot of the management
capability you're used to like
organizational units you can set sign-in
restrictions so ensure that users are
only using the device that you want them
to use so this restricts users from
logging you let's say their personal
gmail account actually access the access
of Chromebook you can actually restrict
it to just your enterprise and then
white listing on black listing of
applications so ensuring that your users
are only in some of the applications
from stores that you want them to be
able to install so we have full
whitelist and blacklist capabilities all
the way down to the Android capabilities
that we now offer on top of Chrome OS
this allows you to curate a publish your
own Google Play Store for your Chrome OS
users and allows them to download
applications or you can also force
install these applications on users and
we have a lot of enterprise integrations
we just reached recently announced more
EMM partnerships in this space so you
can if you would like continue to
leverage the control panel and add these
end-user computing capabilities on top
of it or if you have an existing
end-user computing policy manager you
can continue to use that as well we've
partnered recently with vmware from
their AirWatch product along with some
next-generation providers like Cisco
Meraki mods 360 and some other providers
as well and if you're using existing
Active Directory Integration today with
your
control panel four G's fee that carries
directly over to the devices so whether
using a single sign-on provider you can
also leverage that single sign-on
provider to Delora CLE log into these
workstations and not have to worry about
setting up a whole different policy to
manage these devices and really I talked
a little bit about how we're helping
organizations drive down cost by going
towards Chrome OS there's the easy part
of things right which is these are
generally lower cost devices right so
compared to what we're seeing in the
marketplace most devices that we're
seeing are actually under the cost of
what they're seeing from existing either
windows or mac workstations this
software like licenses are actually
cheaper so as I said there's just the
Chrome Enterprise license we're not
requiring that you go out and your
license of firewall vendor your
licensing and antivirus vendor and
anti-malware and encryption vendor
there's none of those audio costs so you
can actually drive down their software
licensing caused by leveraging this
platform as well these are built to be a
mobile platform think of them very
similarly to your mobile devices so
we're very conscious of power
consumption and making sure we're
keeping that as low as possible
so we're actually seeing reduce power
class as well and from a support
perspective I brought that up earlier so
think of the time and money that goes
into reimaging workstations redeploying
new workstations Chrome OS devices are
really meant to be shareable it comes
from their legacy in education where
thousands of students may share
thousands of devices and you want to be
able to swap those in between and we
think that that's exactly what our
enterprise customers are asking for so
the ability to quickly soccer
workstation get a user up and running
immediately without the kind of time and
maintenance that goes into reimaging a
workstation and giving them something
with less capability than they're used
to today and then administrative cost
this is a platform that's built to be
easy to manage hopefully you see the
same capabilities with our G suite
platform today so again leveraging them
at cloud-based console there's not a lot
of agents that you have to install we're
not asking for a lot of different
integration points here and it's tightly
coupled with the investment that you've
already made in G suite today so
leveraging those management capabilities
on top of this and use your computing
device as well and then economic
benefits so increased productivity we
are
mildly focused on making sure users are
becoming as productive as possible as
quickly as possible on top of these
devices so if you've ever interacted
with a Chrome OS device you know that
they're quick Daboo somewhere average
between six to eight seconds that is the
same whether the device is booting for
the first time booting after the users
use the workstation for a while or
booting after let's say an update that's
just come down so think about some of
the workstations that you use today I
just recently had to update a an
existing device that I had that was
running on a different operating system
and that single little update that had
to be applied to my workstation took
forty seven minutes on Chrome OS our
updates only takes six seconds for the
end user
and it's completely abstract 'add right
so again trying to bring those
innovations that we've seen in the
mobile space to people on their laptops
because this is what users have come to
expect but they don't expect it out of
their computers today and we think that
we can greatly change that reduce down
time we truly believe that these should
be a shareable platform so being able to
easily share these amongst users so if
my workstations ever done I could
quickly pick up a Chromebook on the
other side of the room and instantly be
up and operational with it and then
reduce security risks I've talked about
this already but really baking in all
the security capabilities that you would
come to expect out of a next generation
platform right again as you go out and
you purchase your mobile devices you're
not thinking about how do I enable
encryption on the device how do I go
through and you know download a firewall
and license that firewall and then
license that AV capability we expect all
that of a box and we think that truly
and users should expect that out of the
box as well as long as as well as you as
an enterprise customer so we baked all
that directly into our platform there's
no additional management and we're using
next-generation security capabilities
like you see on a lot of mobile
platforms to reduce security risk on top
of the devices along with giving you
controls and capabilities that if you
want to prevent things like data
exfiltration so preventing users from
logging into the device meant users from
plugging in USB thumb drives it's as
single as easy as a single click to
disable that via the policy manager in
the cloud and as I talked about we're
really really focused on making users
more and more productive right hit that
power button and be up and running and
operational as fast as possible is a
court
tended to what we do on the Chrome OS
devices so what we wanted to do is bring
additional capabilities we've often
heard I want to go with Chrome but we're
missing a lot of applications so we
think by bringing the Android Google
Play Store over that were able to bridge
that gap for the first time we're
actually seeing capabilities like if a
user needs to install Excel on their
workstation you can actually install
Excel directly from the Play Store on
your Chrome OS device and again being
able to curate these applications for
your users so they now have unfettered
access to the capabilities out there of
the Google Play Store you can really
lock them into the applications that are
core to your business often customers
believe that you have to be online to
leverage a Chrome OS device which is not
true we actually have offline
capabilities so whether you're using
next-generation progressive web apps or
using Android application capabilities
we have built-in offline capability so
you can absolutely continue to use these
devices if your users are offline and we
think that if you're leveraging the
Chrome browser on desktop which are
hopefully using today to access G suite
that we want that to be a really
seamless experience so if you're using
existing chrome browser policies
applying those same browser policies to
users as they're working directly on
Chrome OS devices so it's a very fluid
experience and the expectations of the
user are met no matter which device that
they're currently working on we also
allow integrated sync capabilities
rights of syncing applications and user
profiles again inherent to the platform
so a user when they first sign into a
Chrome OS device it actually looks like
it's almost reimaging itself as a tree
downloads all the applications applies
all the user settings directly to it and
harun to the platform of the
capabilities that we offer on the cloud
and again I talked about those security
capabilities so making sure were
isolating processes on top of these
where it's an Android application or
you're actually installing a progressive
web app making sure that these
applications as they become more and
more complex that these complexities
aren't causing security vulnerabilities
on top of our platform something we're
hyper focusing on on the chrome team and
then what often comes up is I'm very
used to Chrome OS in education right
which is really great if I want to go
out and purchase a $230 Chromebook but
it's a little different for me as an
enterprise customer and there was
actually a large variety of
enterprise-grade of
Isis that we offer for chrome customers
across a variety of different
manufacturers for your front line your
worker where you may have a more
ruggedized use case this could be you
know out there with a field worker
possibly in a retail location on the
Acer Chromebook 14 and Lenovo ThinkPad
13 are great options these devices are
meant to be shared if they need to
occasionally be dropped for whatever
reason that's certainly available as
well so you have the capability to move
these devices around and not be too
concerned about if the device were to
suddenly break and the nice part is is
inherently to Chrome OS if the device is
broken you could easily hand that person
another device and they'd be instantly
up and operational with their profile
and more of I need more of an experience
where it's a let's say a more flagship
device it's got a better build quality
these may be fixed sitting on people's
desktops or they may be assigned
directly to certain users HP's built a
really great business Chrome book called
the HP Chromebook 13 with a really great
display on it that's been very popular
with our customers asus has also created
the c300 shoe which is a great platform
with a great build quality and the C 302
is actually fully convertible as well so
you can convert it to tablet mode to
access Android applications and a web
apps directly on there as well just by
flipping it over and really for the next
generation the person that needs the
best device within your organization we
have a Chromebook for them as well so
google recently late last year
introduced our pixel book line the pixel
book is a it's a device really built for
next-generation capabilities so that
includes a pen that you can purchase
optionally for the device as well
built-in Google assistant and really
next generation of processors all the
way up to i7 processors with 16 gigs of
ram so really meant to be a really
powerful device and Samsung has done a
great job of also building a pro-level
device called the Samsung Chromebook pro
this also as it can the availability to
become a convertible and it has a built
in pen as well this has been really
popular for customers Samsung makes
great devices as has been a great Chrome
OS partner and building lots of
different varieties of form factors and
the Samsung Pro has been very popular
and there's even a lower-cost option
with this Samsung Chromebook plus
so we talked about the you know the
economics the integrations that go into
leveraging Chrome OS for your existing G
suite users overall there is a lower
total cost of ownership whether we're
talking about soft cost with you know
how long it takes to spin up a new
device how long it takes to support a
user right there soft costs there but
also a hard cost these are generally
cheaper devices right they're generally
the licensing on is much simpler because
you're just purchasing the Chrome
Enterprise license
versus some of the other capabilities
out there where you'd have to license
additional software vendors that exist
out there today when you take a look at
actually integrating it directly within
G suite as you can see here there is a
much higher or why because you're
directly guiding users towards these
applications you're getting the best of
Google delivered to your end-users so
quick end points to boot up get them
instantly up and collaborative directly
within the platform and are highly
shareable device which is exactly what
we try to offer with G SWE's that
capabilities to be more social with your
your documents most social from an
intranet perspective offering those
capabilities to be more social and more
shareable on top of Chrome OS as well
there's a hard time savings that goes
with this platform right so the ability
to quickly boot up quickly shoot shut
down that no matter what I always know
that my device is going to be working
for me I'm not concerned about charging
it constantly I have built-in
capabilities in here right where I know
that by default the device is gonna boot
up quickly and be a belt available to me
as quick as possible an increase in G
suite adoption these devices drive users
to really leverage the GCP capabilities
out there today so that's things like
you know built-in offline capabilities
whether you're leveraging things like
Gmail or Google Drive inherently built
into a platform and again it makes it
much easier for a user to flip open a
laptop and instantly get to the Google
apps that they need within G suite
without being concerned about all the
other details that go into them having
to use another workstation I wanted to
talk a few minutes about a couple
customer references that we have out
there these are existing GP customers
both
have been on G suite for many many years
but I'm gonna quickly read their quote
from whirlpool because I think it's a
great use case around leveraging
next-generation devices with an
organization your pile familiar with and
probably have a little bit of their
products within your within your
household but at Whirlpool Corporation
we want technology to empower employees
to do great things Chrome OS has helped
our organization do just that by
enabling employees to be their most
productive whenever and wherever
utilizing cloud ready devices
specifically Chromebooks and G suite has
fostered a safer more secure and faster
user experience for both customers and
employees as I talked about this is one
of the core tenants that we've built
into Chrome devices right that I want to
make sure that my users are able to flip
open a workstation instantly work when
they need to be able to and the device
kind of gets out of the way right this
is what people have come to expect with
their mobile platforms but they don't
expect it from the actual workstations
that they're doing their day-to-day work
on and by leveraging cloud ready devices
that are directly integrated into the G
suite experience we think you can make
your end-users even more happy being
able to leverage more Google technology
to help them get their jobs back faster
and some really interesting stats that
came out of whirlpool right that it only
took some months for them to get pay
back on their investment into the Chrome
OS technology
it was a almost 300% return of an
investment versus where they came from
before we talked about that lower TCO
right but think about the the ability to
have lower cost devices in a variety of
form factors with simplified licensing
it's probably one of the many reasons
that you made investments in G suite is
a simplified licensing model the turnkey
ability of the platform and that's
exactly what we're offering with Chrome
OS today and just generally faster to
deploy I think customers often look at
Chrome OS and believe that it has as a
legacy in education so it's built to be
just an education only platform but most
education organizations when they're
dealing with deploying end-user
computers they're not dealing with
deploying Chromebooks so you know 30
users are 50 users these are often one
or two administrators having to deploy
sometimes thousands if
tens of thousands of devices across
their end-user population and as you can
imagine especially younger students can
be very demanding of their devices right
so if there's a way to get in there
install applications they want to be
able to install they're gonna find a way
to do that so that legacy from education
we're now seeing carry over into what
we're consistently hearing from our
customers and deploying Chrome OS and
deploying next generation and user
computing technology is I want to be
able to deploy these faster I want to be
able to set a policy and Institute
employ whether it's thousands or tens of
thousands of devices I want to be able
to leverage the management capabilities
that I already have I don't want to buy
another tool that's another server after
install or another cloud contract that I
have to get from an another existing
provider I want this directly integrated
into the collaboration platform that
I've already made investments in here so
what we like to say is Chrome's are very
set it and forget it technologies to go
in you configure the initial policy
settings and then from there it's very
easy to deploy these these devices at
mass scale and once you configure those
policies they carry across a variety of
form factors whether it's a desktop form
vector a laptop form factor and now just
recently in the education space we
announced a tablet form factor with Acer
so being able to leverage different form
factors and it doesn't make a difference
what form factor you want to use it's
the same exact of policies being applied
it just depends on what capabilities
that platform has which policies are
actually going to apply but as next
generation Chrome OS devices come out
you know that instantly adopt those so
when the pixel book came out if you're
an existing chrome OS customer you just
purchase a pixel book you enroll it into
your domain as long as you have a
management license and the device is
fully managed that's it no new image to
build no additional capabilities they
have to go through the concern about
it's very easy to use next-generation
devices built directly in and another
great reference customer you may have
heard of previously is a company called
CN Mina that does manufacturing and
they're been a really great GC customer
as well and I just want to read a quick
quote from them chrome is empowering
everyone in the organization to be a
cloud worker with the help of Chrome OS
were a lot more efficient and a lot more
secure than we were before
cloud worker is at the core
what we're focused on here on the chrome
team we want to deliver next-generation
computing capabilities so we want to be
able to adopt the next great thing that
comes out from an application standpoint
whether that's progressive web apps or
mobile apps so by tightly integrating
and listening to our customers and
understanding how do we do things like
you know fill an application gaps we
we've heard from customers that
sometimes I need to run a legacy
application right I need to deploy an S
ap application help me do that so we
have existing partnerships out there
with organizations like Citrix or VMware
to be able to deploy these applications
virtually on the platform or again
offering the full Google Play ecosystem
of applications out there as well built
directly into the platform and fully
managed via the G suite management
console and to get started from here if
you have an existing G suite a comment
or feel free to reach out to him or her
to inquire about these capabilities as a
GC customer you can instantly go out
there and download Chrome Enterprise
licenses so if you want to try this and
haven't tried it previously it's as easy
from your management console so just try
if you go under your licensing tab
you'll see an option to start a Chrome
Enterprise trial license we'd love to
talk to you and your team about
next-generation computing capabilities
so now stay tuned for a live
question-and-answer and we will be back
in less than a minute thanks
you
I'm not gonna take us through that a
question answer portion of this and get
to and all the questions they had and
there's some really great ones here
today so I'm gonna start with question
number one to get all of the support
mentioned does the hardware have to be
Google Hardware or can it be a
Chromebook from any device manufacturer
so to get the policies that I talked
about management through the management
console or leveraging existing EMM
partners like VMware with their AirWatch
platform you can use any Chrome OS
device that's out there today so it does
not have to be Google manufactured you
can go and procure from your favorite
hardware vendor a Lenovo and HP whatever
your favorite hardware is out there you
can take that and enroll it to your
management console and get the same
level of management capabilities on top
of it at the end of the day choosing a
Chromebook comes down to your favorite
manufacturer and the type of hardware
specs that you're looking for you make
that choice and you'll have the same
level capability no matter which
manufacturer you choose what kind of off
device log aggregation is available so
being cloud connected gives us the
ability to really aggregate a lot of the
data that end-users what their
interactions are with the device what
the current status is of the device so
if you're coming from the G sweet side
of things you're used to being able to
leverage our API is to pull off
different pieces of G sweet information
and you can leverage that same
capability to actually use our Chrome OS
device inventory API that would allow
you to actually pull information
directly from the management console and
we're constantly looking at ways to
innovate in this space and bring
additional login capabilities but keep
in mind there is a full asset management
tool that is built directly into this
management console so you can see the
status of your devices the last time
they were reduced all the way down to
the hard disk current utilization down
to the CPU temperature so really
granular asset management capabilities
built directly into the device is local
storage on a Chromebook encrypted and
how is it encrypted so chrome devices by
default are encrypted every single
Chrome OS device currently available out
there whether we're talking about a
chrome box that you know list price for
in the mid what hundreds to the flagship
pixel but device every single one has to
be built to our reference and that
reference absolutely includes encryption
capability with a built-in TPM that
means we have encryption all the way
down to the operating system the hard
drives all the way up to the individual
user profiles so as a new user starts to
use the device they'll be encrypted by
default as well and there's nothing else
that you have to additionally set up on
top of the platform
it comes baked directly in so there is
no such thing as an unencrypted Chrome
OS device that would be enrolled to your
domain something else to keep in mind is
that all the policy capabilities are
stored cache locally on that device as
well so again leveraging that encryption
that's built in inherently to it and
then you can also control full
capabilities so making sure users aren't
taking let's say an unencrypted thumb
drive and plugging that into the side of
the device you have the capability of
making sure that that's disabled from a
policy perspective as well with Chrome
Enterprise can you download the Chrome
OS version the answer is yes with a
little bit of a star at the end of it so
at any point if you ever need to roll
back a device or factory reset a device
we absolutely have those capabilities
again this is meant to be a very easy
platform to scale so if you're ever at
the point let's say you're testing
something in our latest beta channel or
developer channel and you want to roll
back to the previous stable version it's
as easy as taking a thumb drive plugging
it directly into a Chrome OS device and
running the recovery utility the
recovery utility will actually flash a
new version of the OS so the thumb drive
and then it's as easy it's about a
five-minute procedure on the device to
actually roll it back to a previous
version and we're continuing to look in
the space and see ways that we can
better improve that for our customers as
well how effective our Chromebooks
offline it depends it comes down to what
the applications are and what kind of
data is that they're looking for like
any other traditional web application of
the users expecting to be online the
offline capabilities are going to be
fractured but we have offline
capabilities across G suite built
directly into the platform so whether
that's gmail calendar or Google Drive
you have that built in also keep in mind
that if you're leveraging things within
the Android ecosystem so you're putting
Google Play applications directly on
these devices a lot of those
applications leverage offline capability
it's a very popular use case especially
in the personal world where people want
to use some type of application out
there out there to download movies when
they're offline on an airplane so
offline
access is completely supported on these
devices and it comes down to the
applications and how they're trying to
look for data and certainly we as your
technical team can go through your list
applications and figure out offline
capabilities making sure those can be
leveraged on top of Chrome OS as well I
will also note that there are html5
offline capabilities built into the
platform as well so if there's existing
html5 offline applications that you are
using those will continue to work on
this platform and those are kind of
baked in so it's usually no user has to
go in and do any interaction or download
an application it's usually they just
use the web app as they're normally used
to and though that data will be
available offline to them what are some
of the top security policies that IT
utilizes the most in the admin console
so at last I checked I believe we have
over 250 different policies inside the
management console so it's always a lot
to go through there but I'll focus in on
some of the the key use cases what we've
seen from a policy perspective so a very
popular policy we often see is just
directly at the seinem which is if I'm
leveraging single sign-on capabilities I
want to be able to make sure that that
Chrome OS device has access to that SSO
provider so if you're using a
third-party that's not Google I'm
setting that policy is very very popular
for enterprise customers also a very
popular device setting is something
called the ephemeral mode what that
means as users log in and interact with
the device they're downloading
applications let's say from the the
curated Google Play Store or they have
other capabilities are downloading
documents ephemeral means when that user
leaves their session it's automatically
going to like that session so that's
very very popular especially in
regulated industries from there the most
popular is really limiting the set of
application so making sure users aren't
going out and downloading applications
they say don't be using so going through
white listing and black listing certain
applications extensions and Google Play
applications directly in the management
console is very very popular as well and
then from there a lot of browser
settings are very very popular for our
customers so it's things like disabling
incognito mode
Papo possibly white listing black
listing certain URL set access or
certain URLs have access to things like
notifications in the platform are very
very popular we see a lot of browser
utilization and that's a very popular
setting that users have available
them in the management console as well
but thank you very much for your
questions please tune in next Tuesday
for the next cloud on air take care